we begin with a problem Alice and Bob
live in tree forts which are far apart
with no line of sight between them and
they need to communicate so they decide
to run a wire between the two houses
they pull the wire tight and attach a
tin can to each end allowing them to
send their voices faintly along the wire
however there is a problem
noise whenever there is a high wind it
becomes impossible to hear the signal
over the noise so they need a way to
increase the energy level of the signal
to separate it from the noise this gives
Bob an idea they can simply plug the
wire which is much easier to detect over
the noise but this leads to a new
problem how do they encode their
messages as plucks well since they want
to play board games across a distance
they tackle the most common messages
first the outcome of two dice rolls in
this case the messages they are sending
can be thought of as a selection from a
finite number of symbols in this case
the eleven possible numbers which we
call a discrete source at first they
decide to use the simplest method they
send the result as the number of plucks
so to send a three they send three
plucks nine is nine plucks and twelve is
twelve plucks however they soon realize
that this takes much longer than it
needs to
from practice they find that their
maximum pluck speed is - plucks per
second any faster and they will get
confused so - plucks per second can be
thought of as the rate or capacity for
sending information in this way and it
turns out that the most common roll is a
seven so it takes 3.5 seconds to send
the number 7 Alice then realizes they
can do much better if they change their
coding strategy she realizes that the
odds of each number being sent follows a
simple pattern there is one way to roll
a 2 2 ways to roll a 3 3 ways to roll a
4 4 ways to roll a 5 5 ways to roll a 6
and 6 ways to roll a 7 the most common
and five ways to roll an eight four ways
for a nine and so on back to one way for
a 12 and this is a graph showing the
number of ways each result can occur and
the pattern is obvious so now let's
change the graph to number of plucks
versus each symbol she proceeds by
mapping the most common number seven to
the shortest signal one pluck
she then proceeds to the next most
probable number and if there is a tie
she picks one at random in this case she
selects six to be two plucks and then
eight to be three plucks and then back
to five to be four plucks and nine is
five bucks and back and forth until we
reach 12 which is assigned to 11 plucks
now the most common number seven can be
sent in less than a second a huge
improvement this simple change allows
them to send more information in the
same amount of time on average in fact
this coding strategy is optimal for this
simple example and that it's impossible
for you to come up with a shorter method
of sending to dice rolls using identical
plucks
however after playing with the wire for
some time bob hits on a new idea
you
you